you guys may have noticed that most of
our iPad videos are done by vadim it's
not like I don't like iPads I just like
Mac books better but after this new
release and the new software updates I
decided to finally give up my new
MacBook Air that I've been using for a
while and give the new iPad pro ago in
this video I'm gonna share with you all
the real-world differences that jumped
out at me after being switched over for
a bit something I was expecting while
others I definitely wasn't and there
were surprises and along with that I'll
let you guys know if I'm switching to
the iPad pro for my basic daily uses
let's start out with something that I've
been pleading for in my Mac books for a
while now and that is face ID now
logging in is pretty quick you just have
to swipe up maybe with the new keyboard
they're gonna change that so it's
automatic but where it's super nice to
have is being in Safari and using Safari
autofill and in apps where it just logs
in automatically the next thing that I
notice is that the touch screen is
surprisingly useful now at first that
was kind of weird just pecking at the
screen all the time but I did have to
use it because I don't have a trackpad
and I did find that for certain things
it is quite handy one of those is being
able to just move my pointer if I'm
writing up a document exactly where I
want it pretty much instantly by
touching I also used it for scrolling
and for gestures and I know those of you
guys that are using Windows laptops your
guys are used to this but I'm personally
not because Mac books don't have
touchscreens
and it was quite comfortable and handy
to do so and think of another part of
that was the iPad pros 120 Hertz screen
which makes it just feel so fluid to be
able to scroll through pages now the
first day I kept accidentally trying to
reach down for the trackpad and move my
screen around and get my pointer but
obviously it is not there on this
keyboard but as you guys know that's
gonna be changing really soon
I used the bridge Pro keyboard and even
though it's the best option available
right now I have to be honest and say
that it does not compare to the new
magic keyboard in the MacBook Air one
thing that really bugged me was deleting
sentences when I'm writing because it
just goes at one constant speed and it
is just annoying and another thing is
trying to select portions
of text by touching and then hitting the
select there's just much quicker having
a track read for that even though the
keys field II said they're just a bit
too small and for long typing sessions
my fingers feel too cramped and get
tired the display also felt a bit
cramped now I have the 11 inch version
but if you're trying to replace a
MacBook I would suggest a 12-point 9
inch version thankfully the iPad
displays use a more squared aspect ratio
and just like the keyboard for most
tasks I got used to it now even though
the display is smaller that doesn't mean
that the display is worse in fact for
many things the display is much better
the iPad screen can display more colors
which is better if you want to edit
images or video but that didn't matter
to me what did matter was the display
brightness the MacBook Air only reaches
350 minutes so that means if you're in a
bright room where you're outdoors that
could be limiting the iPad on the other
hand reaches 600 nits that's almost
twice as bright and it's definitely
handy at times heck even the best Mac
the pros only reach 500 nits the other
thing that I noticed the difference in
was playing back video I noticed that
the quad speakers sound more immersive
when watching movies but they are
quieter so that was a downside
especially if my kids are running around
another difference is that even though
the display has almost twice as much
pixels as a 1080p screen you can't
select worke in YouTube which I do all
the time on the MacBook Air for better
quality
now 1080p looks fine on an 11 inch
screen and also saves battery but that
would be an even bigger bummer if you
bought the 12 point 9 inch iPad now talk
about battery life I did notice some
differences I would say probably roughly
one to maybe two hours less real-world
uses for mixed productivity tasks appear
to the MacBook Air but along with that I
was pushing the display you know with
higher brightness level so that does
have something to do with it now if
you're somebody that does a lot of web
conferencing or facetiming the 7
megapixel camera on the iPad pro
absolutely destroys the 720p webcam on
the MacBook Air which equates to roughly
1.2 megapixels one issue did come up
though
if you're using the iPad as a laptop
with the keyboard attached the
front-facing camera not only is on the
left-hand side but it's also lowered
down so when you're talking to somebody
if you're looking at the screen and
looking at the person it looks like
you're looking off to the side and kind
of ignoring them and which is much less
of an issue on the MacBook Air now of
course with the iPad you can always take
it out of the case or your keyboard and
flip it up and hold it in your hand but
if you need to be able to do some
researching some typing at the same time
obviously most of the keyboard cases
they do not offer that orientation I
also want to mention the rear cameras
obviously MacBooks don't have those and
even though I'm not somebody who's gonna
take photos and videos or with these and
they actually turn out quite good as far
as quality I did use it to scan a
document and that is very convenient
being able to do that you also get lidar
for augmented reality and that might be
convenient for some people but I just
didn't use that and one thing that is
missing on the iPad is a headphone jack
now personally most of the time I end up
using my ear pods anyway so it's not
something that was an inconvenience to
me there's not many ways to quantify the
performance difference between these two
but I use browser bench in Safari and
the iPad scored a hundred and fifty
compared to the already quite high score
of 112 that the MacBook Air got now in
the real world the iPad did feel a
little bit more snappy but that could
have just been that 120 Hertz screen
that makes everything feel super quick
the other thing I never got was heat on
my lap which is sometimes noticeable
after using the MacBook Air for a while
comparing a few more metrics in
Geekbench 5 the iPad scores a massive
4600 88 compared to my best ever score
with the air that was 3934 and that's a
score I got when I liquid cooled my
macbook air out of the box they got 3231
while running quite hot there's also an
i7 option for the MacBook Air but it
doesn't run much faster because the
MacBook Air has an adequate cooling for
these quad-core processors the other
performance difference is Wi-Fi the new
iPad pro supports Wi-Fi six
and in the toughest section of my house
it still managed 192 megabit per second
out of my maximum 250 whereas the
MacBook Air only got 96 because it only
supports Wi-Fi 5 on the graphic side
that the story is similar my ears new g7
graphics scored high but the iPad is
even better at almost 10,000 medal score
now most people who buy a MacBook Air
aren't needing the greatest graphics but
just so you know more and more regular
normal apps are using graphics
acceleration now for example photo
editing I did some photo editing using
Lightroom and while the air does a
decent job the iPad is actually smoother
in general many tasks feel faster on the
iPad which is likely due to apps being
more optimized because they are built
from the ground up to support metal and
the processors in these iPads that is
something that I have to touch on the
apps applications were the thing that
was tying me most to Mac OS and Mac
books but in the last year Apple finally
gave us a usable file system with
external drive support and many
companies have really stepped it up with
powerful apps like Photoshop luma fusion
and affinity zaps in fact it seems like
more companies now are putting their
main focus on iPad apps and mobile apps
not only do we have lots of productivity
app options but they are often less
expensive while being really good for
example Pixelmator photo which could be
bought for just $5 in some cases they
actually offer a better experience than
on Mac OS for example using Google Drive
is so much quicker and snappier as an
app on the iPad and along with you know
other apps that they offer and on top of
that if you're somebody that wants to
play games you are much much better off
with an iPad pro compared to a MacBook
Air of course the MacBook Air does have
exclusive apps such as Final Cut which
is not available for the iPad pro at
least just yet but I think overall if we
look at applications and prices the iPad
definitely has the lake up and with that
we haven't even touched on Penn support
now I'm not somebody that uses the Apple
pencil very often I don't draw
don't do things like that but if you're
somebody that likes to design you like
to draw sketch right obviously that is
something you can do with the iPad Pro
and you cannot do with the macbook air
overall I was very impressed with how
well the iPad pro does when being used
as a MacBook Air replacement no it is
not perfect but in most use cases that
you would use that iPad air for this
does it close to as well and in some
cases even better and along with that it
has much much more capabilities for
other use cases you know the cameras the
screen drawing gaming all of that stuff
but you simply can't do on the MacBook
Air after using it as a Mac replacement
I have even less doubt that if you're
only gonna buy one device you should
absolutely get the iPad pro now
obviously I am NOT in that camp
I have a ton of different tech devices
so will I be switching from my MacBook
to an iPad no at least not yet there's
still something great about a standard
well balanced clamshell notebook
especially one like the MacBook Air that
has a fantastic keyboard and trackpad
what I do mostly with my basic device is
web browsing research and scripting and
the MacBook Air just does a better job
at those things iPad software has
finally caught up and it is good enough
but the hardware is just not there yet
which is why I'm really intrigued with
that keyboard now there are gonna be
other options like the new bridge that
has a trackpad but I am guessing that
Apple's is going to be the best one I
think that floating design is going to
be amazing allowing the 11 inch size to
be more usable and it will help in
cramped spaces that extra USB C port
will be nice to charge or for using a
headphone adapter while leaving the
other one available the biggest thing
for me is the keyboard and if it
actually is the same keyboard that is in
the new MacBook Air that will solve the
keyboard issue and it will finally make
the iPad pro be a macbook air killer but
for now I am sticking to my Mac if
you've switched let me know your
experience down in the comments section
below and if you guys want to get the
best deal on a new MacBook
err or maybe an iPad check out the links
in the video description because I want
to see more videos click that circle
above or if you want to see a couple
great videos we have some right over
there this Ben Max and I will see you in
the next video
[Music]